Don't look at me
[Applause] We'll
forget about it in the morning The two of us hiding in the shadows are giving
up everything The purple color disappears Don't let it get taken away Don't let it get taken away You
can't live here, damn it  I'm imagining the relationships that we're
going to sow, and we're all tangled up with our big faces, and we're
not looking back, but we're scattering things, and we're not changing, and we're tying
up
[music], so we
can't make any promises, and we're
still going to grow like this until we grow.  I don't think I'll come out, I'll
hug you and even though my regrets have subsided, I still
want to burn away my sadness and wake up.
[Music]
Only
[Applause]
T